meine damen und herren in diesen stunden
erreichen uns furchtbare und grauen der
regener aufnahmen aus der ukraine wir
sehen dutzende erschossene zivilisten im
buch da ein gebiet nördlich von kiew das
bis vor wenigen tagen vom russischen
militär kontrolliert worden ist straßen
übersät mit leichen notdürftig
verscharrt körper
es ist von frauen kindern und alten die
rede die unter den opfern sind
die ermordung von zivilisten ist ein
kriegsverbrechen
diese verbrechen der russischen
streitkräfte müssen wir schonungslos
aufklären ich verlange dass
internationale organisationen wie das
internationale komitee vom roten kreuz
zugang erhalten zu diesen gebieten und
die gräueltaten dokumentieren die täter
und ihre auftraggeber müssen zur
rechenschaft gezogen werden
der krieg in der ukraine befindet sich
in der sechsten woche tausende
ukrainerinnen und ukrainer sind ihm
schon zum opfer gefallen und das töten
geht unvermindert weiter
ich fordere präsident putin und russland
auf endlich in einen waffenstillstand
einzuwilligen und die kampfhandlungen
einzustellen
es ist ein furchtbarer ein sinnloser ein
durch nichts zu rechtfertigender krieg
der unendlich viel leid erzeugt und
niemandem nutzt er muss aufhören
wir werden im kreis der verbündeten in
den nächsten tagen weitere maßnahmen
beschließen präsident putin und seine
unterstützer werden die folgen spüren
und wir werden der ukraine weiterhin
waffen zur verfügung stellen damit sie
sich gegen die russische invasion
verteidigen kann
vielen dank
dass also der bundeskanzler olaf scholz
an diesem sonntagabend nach den
gräueltaten von butscher wir zeigen
ihnen diese bilder noch einmal dort aus
den straßen dieses vor ort ist dieser
kleinstadt vor kiew die leichen auf den
strassen gefesselt auf dem rücken die
männer die dort liegen die wehrlos waren
und genauso erschossen wurden
hingerichtet wurden diese zivilisten
dort offenbar eben von der russischen
armee die jetzt gute fünf wochen dort
gewütet hat vor den toren kassels heime
uns zugeschaltet und hier im studio mein
kollege bild reporter hans jörg
vehlewald wir haben diese worte des
bundeskanzlers eben gehört zu diesen
bildern die wir sehen ein mann im gully
gestopft dort ermordet 410 zivilisten
dort ja hingerichtet muss man sagen und
der bundeskanzler findet jetzt das wort
kriegsverbrechen dafür und kündigt für
die nächsten tage härtere sanktionen an
paul
ja zumindest das möchte man sagen also
bin ich mir oder schutz dort angeschaut
habe dann habe ich schon das gefühl dass
ich ihn ernsthaft mitgenommen hat das
was er heute gesehen hat das was muss
man vielleicht erklären ja auch ganz
sicher und deutschen geheimdiensten
zumindest teilweise geprüft worden ist
auch aus ihrer sicht denn sonst würde
sich der bundeskanzler nicht so
öffentlich und so klar äußern er nennt
ist kriegsverbrechen was dort passiert
und er hat damit absolut recht denn das
was ich dort gesehen habe und viele
meiner journalistischen kollegen kann
man kaum in worte fassen wenn man dort
die straße lang geht ein schöner vor ort
und hilft es einmal war sieht man
menschen zerfetzt man sieht menschen die
ihre ihre hände verbunden haben die
augen verbunden haben offenbar
hingerichtet wurden in den kopf
geschossen wurden man sieht wie ein mann
der gerade
kartoffeln holen gehen wollte erschossen
wurde also ich habe mindestens mehr als
ein dutzend leichen dort gesehen in den
straßen und bespricht das alles soll
hunderte gewesen sein es gibt auch
massengräber dort offenbar und es ist
ein bild was ist in diesem krieg so
grausame bereits in den letzten sechs
wochen gewesen ist so noch nicht gegeben
hat bezirk viele wald bei uns unser bild
chefreporter nun sagt der bundeskanzler
olaf scholz dazu kriegsverbrechen das
ist politisch wichtig dass so zu
benennen für uns ganz menschlich das
normalste von der welt man guckt er
drauf und sagt natürlich was ist es denn
sonst hansjörg aber politisch hat das
eben jetzt auch noch mal eine neue
dimension
ja es ist das was auch der ukrainische
botschafter heute mit einer wende
angekündigt hatte benannt hat das ist
eine andere situation als die bilder die
wir bisher gesehen haben das offenbart
sich jetzt ganz offensichtlich nur das
was bisher versteckt wurde dadurch dass
die russischen soldaten eben die
menschen gezwungen haben in ihren
häusern zu bleiben sie dann auf der
straße erschossen haben aber niemand von
dort wirklich konkret auch berichten
konnten wir diese bilder bisher nicht
gewinnt gibt versteckt diese gräueltaten
und dafür muss man ehrlich zugeben ist
das wort kriegsverbrechen eben auch aus
dem kanzler mund dass wir jetzt endlich
auch einmal hören
ausgesprochen emotional für die
verhältnisse von olaf scholz ist sehr
emotional
man merkt dass es ihm nahe gegangen ist
er merkt dass jetzt
mindestens starke worte dafür gefunden
werden müssen er hat ja auch angekündigt
dass man sich eben auch im kreis der
nato der eu partner der usa noch weitere
sanktionen wird überlegen müssen wie man
dem begegnen ja das worte die worte sind
das eine paula ist ja ganz klar dass wir
jetzt hier darüber sprechen was hat das
für folgen also wenn von einer wende
jetzt die rede ist von einem wendepunkt
so hat es eben ja auch andere melnik
hierbei bild live bei bild live nochmal
benannt hier der ukrainische botschafter
aber woraus besteht so ein wendepunkt
ich kann ihnen in den worten olaf scholz
noch nicht erkennen dass er kündigt
weitere sanktionen an aber das klingt
jetzt noch nicht nach einem gasstopp und
nach nach noch viel viel umfassender
militärischer hilfe
also das hatte sich der heute noch nicht
festlegt dass es durchaus normal denn
die politik deutschlands ist auch immer
sich mit seinen europäischen nachbarn
abzustimmen am ende bringt ja ein öl und
gas volk dort auch nur etwas wenn das
europäische passiert also nicht mehr in
deutschland dort alleine oder mit
einzelnen ländern
und wir müssen davon ausgehen dass
nehmen wir mal an deutschland werden
mittlerweile bereit das zu machen es
durchaus sein kann dass andere länder
gibt in europa die dagegen sind zum
beispiel ungarn wissen wir muss ungarn
noch sehr sehr lange wladimir putin
unterstützt hat viktor orban ihn ein
freund genannt hat und so weiter also
dass urlaub schuldig sagte ab morgen 12
uhr mittags gibt ein gas und öl boykott
das
macht durchaus sinn auf der anderen
seite konnte man sein worten jetzt auch
nicht entnehmen was er denn persönlich
für richtig hält also da scheint er auch
noch nicht entschlossen zu sein
wahrscheinlich wenn er erst noch weitere
gespräche führen mit seinen eu partnern
wie die am ende aussehen soll aber
werden die stimmen in der
bundesregierung paul und hansjörg
mittlerweile lauter die möglicherweise
diese richtung gehen nach all diesen
wochen krieg nach diesen neuen
kriegsverbrechen dort in botschaft wo
man ja davon ausgehen muss dass es jetzt
nur ein kleiner ausschnitt ist dass das
an vielen anderen orten ganz genau so
passiert ist in der ukraine jetzt nach
fünf wochen krieg also werden diese
stimmen jetzt lauter möglicherweise auch
in der bundesregierung vor allen dingen
in der grünen partei
aber mein eindruck ist das was man jetzt
im moment doch heute von herrn hahn v
berbalk hört das klingt schon beinahe
für grüne verhältnisse genfer nacht nach
säbelrasseln wenn man das hässliche wort
noch mal benutzen will das ist
ungewöhnlich für grün für die grüne
partei und auch ungewöhnlich im moment
auch aus der bundesregierung ich habe
den eindruck dass da der druck eben auch
auf olaf scholz moment wächst
andererseits weiß man von olaf scholz
und jetzt mal an jemand eben lange kennt
gesagt er geht niemals auch nur das
geringste risiko öffentlich ein bevor er
sich nicht intern abgestimmt hat
insofern gebe ich paul völlig recht er
wird sich erst einmal mit den
europäischen partnern absprechen wollen
insbesondere was dann auch ein noch
weitergehen das embargo für energie aus
russland angeht er wird jetzt nicht
vorpreschen und sagen wir machen das
jetzt einfach weil will sich erst mit
den europäischen partnern so weit wie
möglich ab sprechen dann wird er nach
draußen treten ist dass paul
möglicherweise ein strip rené zahnd
moment
das kann zu einem srebrenica moment
werden davon die ich ganz stark aus denn
man merkt ja wie sehr diese bilder die
menschen schauten völlig zu recht jemand
der dort war kann nicht nur sagen das
ist etwas
ja etwas unvorstellbares was man dort
sieht weil es eben um zivilisten geht
wenn man die augenzeugenberichte wir
hatten noch mehrere kollegen dort die
recherchiert haben wir auch das motiv
ist und was man senke unser ukrainischer
kollege der mit menschen gesprochen hat
eben erzählt haben dass ihr mann
erschossen wurde wir wissen von
dingen die dort in den kellern passiert
sein sollen und männer hingerichtet
worden sind wir hören von
vergewaltigungen werden von
massengräbern von daher ja ich glaube es
tritt benutzer ist da wahrscheinlich der
richtige vergleich fast mit den beiden
klitschko-brüdern heute auch dort
unterwegs also in botschaft dass es noch
mal gemeinsam rein hören was wladimir
klitschko ist vor wenigen tagen noch
hier in berlin hier im studio auch dort
ja ja wie er seine erlebnisse dort heute
schildert
die zivilisten die hirschstraße
unterliegen wagen sind die herren wir
man sieht dass sie im kopf
geschossen worden und
exekutiert das ist
das was macht die regime in der ukraine
budisa nie in der ukraine ist vollkommen
das ist kein
etablierter special operation heißt
also dass vladimir klitschko dort heute
in bhutan in dieser kleinstadt forks das
noch mal über diese wörter sprechen
kriegsverbrechen und völkermord hansjörg
warum ist das so wichtig diese worte im
moment auch zu benutzen warum so wichtig
von einem möglichen über einen möglichen
prozess später zu sprechen das hilft
natürlich den menschen in der ukraine im
moment gar nichts nein aber das wird
später bei einem möglichen prozess im
ganz entscheidend seien normalerweise
spricht man bei einem krieg davon das
militär auf militär schießt
ausgebildeter soldat auf ausgebildeten
soldaten und das ist sozusagen das was
wir uns als normalen krieg beschreiben
das kann grausam genug sein aber die
bilder die wir hier sehen man muss sich
das hier wirklich noch mal vor augen
führen wie es dazu kommt dass dort
jemand wir sehen das bild gerade er
liegt jemand vor seinem eingang der
versucht rein oder gerade raus zu kommen
das in dem moment erschossen worden
möglicherweise auch von snipers immer
wieder von scharfschützen die rede das
erklärt auch warum viele dieser leichen
dort jetzt seit tagen bereits liegen die
menschen haben sich einfach nicht auf
die straße getraut um die leichen zu
bergen dazu kommen nach nachrichten
darüber dass manche leichen auch in der
gegend wird mit minen versehen wurden so
dass wenn die berührt werden derjenige
der sie berührt dann mit explodieren
könnte das über tage möglicherweise über
wochen hinweg diese diese dieser
psychokrieg der eben auch stattgefunden
hat und dann die beschreibung von irina
einer frau die dort wohnt die vor ihren
mit ansehen musste wie ihr mann
erschossen wird vorher in die knie gehen
musste und sie dann eben selbst
untersagten wünsche erschießt nicht doch
auch gleich das ist furchtbar das macht
treibt dann würde ich die tränen in die
augen hier sehen wir diese bilder die du
schon angesprochen hast paul auch ein
mann der dort vom kartoffelhof einfach
abgeknallt wird auf der straße offenbar
dann ein anderer mann neben dem der hund
verharrt hat wohl offenbar überall diese
tage und dann wird während er da heute
warte in buschehr
aufgeräumt sozusagen die leichen
weggeschafft in leichensäcken dann
abtransportiert von den straßen geholt
das sind bilder die viele heute
kommentiert haben mit dem wort
unvorstellbar wer allerdings die
russische armee in den vergangenen
jahrzehnten gesehen hat in syrien oder
auch in großen hier in tschetschenien
für den sind diese bilder eigentlich ja
nicht unvorstellbar schon wieder muss
man eigentlich sagen
ja schon wieder und das in einem
nachbarland russlands dem sogenannten
bruder folgt wie man das lange gesagt
hatte jeder ihr in der ukraine hat
verwandte freunde in russland und
umgekehrt also man muss sich auch noch
einmal die dimension vor augen führen
von wohl das gekommen ist also das war
ja wirklich familien die miteinander
waren wo die einen nach russland bezogen
sind und die anderen liga ost ukraine
oder nach ihr ich habe viele freunde die
mir erzählen wie sie eben ihr in der
ukraine immer wieder russischen freunden
telefonieren oder verwandten
telefonieren und sie dann zu hören
bekommen ja aber ihr seid doch eine art
ist und was eure regierung dort macht
also diese propaganda die dazu
funktioniert hat und das versucht man
jetzt ja bereits wieder auch mit diesen
bildern der kreml hat zwar noch nicht
reagiert aber ich stark davon aus dass
man wieder reine propaganda geschichte
erzählen wird warum dort leichen liegen
und wird geschichten erfinden um die
ukraine dafür verantwortlich zu machen
aber ich kann nur sagen also dann ist
der dort war
es liegen dort zivilisten auf der straße
die getötet wurden das sind die fakten
und dass es das woran wir auf nikotin
messen müssen du warst heute dort in
butter paul sag uns aber wie geht es
eigentlich in diesem ort in dieser
kleinstadt jetzt weiter also wir haben
gesehen dass dort ja das ist ein viel zu
banales wort aber dass aufgeräumt wurde
heute erstmal die leichen zur seite
geschafft wurden kannst du sagen was mit
denen eigentlich passiert werden die in
irgendeiner form beigesetzt beerdigt wer
ist dort aktuell in diesem ort ist er
leer gewohnt ansonsten oder ja geht da
wieder springt ja so etwas wie alltag an
also es gibt noch erstaunlich viele
menschen die dort wohnen also ich habe
mit vitali klitschko dann einen mann
getroffen auf der straße der uns dann
sein haus gezeigt hat der brücke
unbedingtes witali und wladimir sich das
anschauen was die russen mit dem haus
gemacht haben wir uns auch berichtet hat
wie viele menschen erschossen worden
sind dass es gibt viele die nicht
rausgegangen sind als die kämpfe losging
und dann war es zu spät dann waren sie
sozusagen eingeschlossen dort und jetzt
ist es so dass vor allem ansonsten
militär in der stadt ist oder in dem ort
ist der bürgermeister natürlich und
offizielle und dort heißt es dass man
jetzt in den nächsten tagen eine
ausgangssperre sind jetzt nicht
journalisten betrifft aber und und nicht
militär betrifft natürlich aber
ansonsten wird man doch nicht dass die
menschen zurück kommen weil man sagt es
ist zu gefährlich es gibt dort zu viele
minen hans jörg kotzan gesprochen es
gibt gerüchte dass auch in diesen
gleichen sozusagen
explosions material versteckt sein
könnte es gibt ein schlachtfeld nach dem
anderen es sind neben den toten diese
ganze verwüstung die man dort sieht also
die häuser die komplett zerschossen sind
man sieht dort auf dem flughafen in der
nähe bei rostock das ist nicht so weit
entfernt und boccia eine komplett
zerstörung dieses flughafens wo einst
die russischen kräfte am anfang des
krieges gelandet sind aber vor allem
bleibt natürlich der blick auf diese
menschen die zivilisten die auf der
straße liegen und tatsächlich wir waren
heute morgen dort als wir am mittag oder
nachmittag aufgebrochen sind wieder
zurück nach kiel hat man immer mehr
damit begonnen sozusagen die menschen
die toten dort ja im gleichen häuser zu
bringen denn auch das war natürlich in
den vergangenen tagen nicht möglich denn
dieser krieg oder der kampf ging dort
bis vor wenigen tagen kein und auch die
russischen kräfte scheinbar abgezogen
haben sie noch weiter mit artillerie und
raketen auf den ort gefeuert hans jörg
vehlewald bei uns im studio was passiert
jetzt weiter in der bundesregierung
innerhalb der europäischen union als wir
haben gerade die kanzler gesehen der das
erstmalig als kriegsverbrechen
bezeichnet hat was dort von der
russischen armee begangen ist in dem ort
butscher also was passiert jetzt in den
nächsten stunden wie ist der weg zu
weiteren härteren sanktionen ich glaube
dass man sich zunächst einmal sehr genau
überlegen wird welche abwehrwaffen man
noch zusätzlich schicken kann wie
schnell so etwas gehen kann wie viel
geld auch dafür möglicherweise noch
extra zur verfügung stehen muss was die
sanktionen angeht werden glaube die
staaten die betroffenen sind bzw die
jetzt agieren könnten sich weiterhin
immer noch überlegen nützt es denn
den druck jetzt wirklich noch weiter zu
erhöhen müssten nicht in wahrheit ein
komplett embargo stattfinden also
wirklich die energie importe aus
russland auf null zu setzen wenn sie
sagen man das nämlich nicht tut wird
möglicherweise nicht genug sein so
schwer wird es auch sein